[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back more now on our top story
and we're going to devote the rest of
the hour to the Chancellor's Financial
plans and how they affect you we've been
asking for your questions today and our
panel is here to help answer some of
them joining me is Zoe Billingham the
director of the ippr north Think Tank
Lord Jim O'Neill former treasury
Minister and former Chief Economist at
Goldman Sachs and here with me in the
studio is Andy Mayer CEO CEO and energy
Analyst at The Institute of economic
Affairs a very good evening to all of
you thank you very much for your time uh
perhaps first of all I'll get you all in
one sentence to sum up your thoughts on
today's mini budget so Andy why don't
you start so the government is obsessed
with growth and has delivered a growth
plan they've done it in the right way
they're lowering taxes and they're
starting the process of supply side
reform which means getting out of the
way so companies businesses and
individuals can focus on growth okay uh
that was a very good sentence Lord
O'Neill same to you
most remarkable budget I've ever lived
through uh even though it's not supposed
to be a good budget
um
a generous person might call it
audacious
um
I've been thinking that on and off all
day but I can think of Plenty other
phrases including potentially Reckless
as you can see how the financial markets
are behaving as we speak
okay and Zoe
so today's budget was deeply problematic
both for those of us who care about
inequality but it should also be
problematic for those who care about
economic growth now I I care about both
of those things and so it leaves me with
a bad taste in my mouth from today's
budget okay so right that's uh all of
your takes on what we heard earlier
let's go to some of the questions shall
we starting with one from Jay he asks
why has the government chosen to reduce
tax more for the higher earners than for
those on Lower incomes Lord O'Neill
perhaps you could kick things off for us
I don't know
um yeah link link to what I uh said
initially
the the scale of fiscal stimulus in
itself that the government has decided
to do all in one shot
at the time when the issues about
inflation are around and crucially
uh many concerns in global markets
particularly led by the US
uh it's almost like they haven't thought
about the fact that we were not living
in our own isolated world it's I think
it's and it's politically obviously a
very risky thing for them to have done
and it's very much against the spirits
of so-called leveling up which they were
both uh the Prime Minister and the
chancellor were seemingly consented
members of the government that seemingly
was so committed to that
but Andy uh in effect all workers do
benefit don't they from this budget yeah
yeah and it's not the test the test on
the high-profile tax cuts which may or
may not benefit the wealthy more than
others is should they be there in the
first place the government isn't setting
out to increase inequality it's looking
at the whole picture and saying if we do
these things in the long term it will
mean more growth and we're all richer
and some of this is a bit hypocritical
so when the National Insurance rallies
came in they were attacked from the left
as being an assault on working people
and an assault on the leveling up agenda
and now that that's been canceled it's
all about the rich apparently so I think
those on the left need to make up their
minds are they going to welcome the
parts of the package that do make sense
while retaining their criticism for
those bits that don't Zoe your thoughts
so I think when we look at the overall
package of tax cuts today we see that
it's deeply regressive
um so that means that the wealthier you
are the more you benefit from this
package so I would say
um this is goes hand in hand with
economic growth because actually what
we're seeing today is a reversion to
trickle-down economics where you believe
making rich people richer will simply
trickle down and benefit everybody else
well that model has been shown to have
failed even the international monetary
fund no longer hold on to trickle-down
economics as the right economic model so
I think if you care about growth but if
you also care about inequality the
budget today was deeply troubling on
both counts okay uh well let's stick
with uh trickle-down economics then
because Stewie has asked about that he
says are they proven to work from what I
can see this budget does nothing for the
average hard-working family uh so he has
pretty much answered that question
already so let's get the thoughts of
Andy on that well trickle-down economics
is a 130 year old slur by Democratic
party presidential candidate in a long
gone election it's never been the policy
of any Administration British or
American and it is simply an idea that
the whole way politics and economics
works is around redistribution which is
not the point of this budget the point
of this budget is supply side reform
which is about getting regulations out
of the way when the government has been
interfering in markets and ensuring that
people can invest money in
infrastructure in new Industries in
ensuring that our energy challenge can
be solved so it's just irrelevant
frankly it's gonna it's gonna dominate
the debate because the lingo is great
it's a really brilliant piece of jargon
but it doesn't mean anything okay Jim is
Stewie right when he says that this mini
budget has nothing for the average
hard-working family
it's not got as much for the average
hard-working families for the wealthy
because of the nature of the tax cuts
but uh linked to my tone it's got
something for everyone
um you know it's a huge fiscal stimulus
as I think uh I heard the ifs say it's
probably the biggest net fiscal stimulus
since the the famous 1972 budget and I
know Andy uh and uh is trying to put it
all in political terms but you know I'm
independent of either political party I
see it as an independent member of the
Lords and a an economist and it it it
and at a minimum it's it's very risky in
order for this to work
lots of things have to not go wrong and
the only thing that's happened today and
it you know the the financial markets in
New York are still open and I've spent
getting on for 35 years deeply involved
in them and and the markets are sending
messages that they are quite bothered by
what has happened today you've got
you've had an enormous rise in uh guilt
yields on a daily basis point nearly 50
basis points and as of five minutes ago
before we started a three and a half
percent drop in Sterling and if we have
another couple of days about that to be
honest I think uh some people advising
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
might be suggesting you know what you
might have to rain back on some of the
things that are happening because the
bank of England will have to consider
raising rates even more aggressively
than they might have done 24 hours ago
again and so the consumers are gonna who
anybody that borrows are going to get
hurt by all of that as well so yeah and
you mentioned that you mentioned
side reforms that Andy talks about in
principle are exactly what the country
needs to boost its productivity rate but
you do not combine that at the same time
with a ginormous fiscal stimulus just
after you've announced an enormous
package to support everybody through the
energy crisis when everybody's freaking
out about inflation it is just extremely
risky okay uh yeah and they took that
risk in 1972 as you mentioned in it and
it didn't it didn't pay off then let's
go to this question from Max
um pretty short and sweet really does
this budget have the potential to
bankrupt the UK Zoe
well certainly
um the measures taken today tax cut
measures are using up the fiscal space
we have left and that means the amount
of additional debt we can take on as a
country as Jim has said the markets have
responded very negatively to this news
with the pound almost now on a par with
the dollar so that's a bad sign
um so I would say using up your fiscal
space at this time gives no room for
maneuver later when the government will
still need to help and support those at
the lowest end of the spectrum and who
will still face significant energy price
Rises this winter Andy
um as Max was saying is bankrupt in the
UK are possible or will growth as the
government hopes pay these bills no
we're not going to be doing anything
like that and the market correction in
the currencies is important and
significant I agree the market reaction
has been poor but it is not a
catastrophe and it is the immediate
reaction and let's see what actually
happens over the next few weeks okay all
right plenty more questions after the
break don't go away
[Music]
I'm Hannah Thomas Peter and I'm Skye's
climate change correspondent
the UK is a world leader in wind power
[Music]
it's part of the Congo Basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lands of Africa we aim
to be the best and most trusted place
for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
naive but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these the sofas and people's desks
and children's books and you can see
inside this home here people trying to
uh to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future of you and me
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to Sky News Tonight
straight back to your questions on
today's mini budget with our expert
panel uh Michael has been in touch how
long before we start seeing the growth
that this plan is supposed to elicit
will it be instant or will it take years
what do you reckon Jim
well as I uh keep referring to
you know a lot of things aren't directly
under the control of those who've made
these decisions we live in a Global
Financial market and if we see many days
of what we've seen today and hopefully
we won't but if we do and having been in
them once these things start they don't
just sort of magically stop
um it's going to cause problems a
facetious person would say if it comes
on like this the so-called November
budget might have to be an emergency
budget the other way because it is a
pretty dramatic move we've seen today by
any of the standards that I've uh lived
through to do with UK budgets yeah I
mean and so it's quite it's quite
serious and and that will mean that the
the economic the consequences for the
real economy despite the intention of
the government uh will be worse
so uh eventually something will happen
and we'll get more growth but the way
this has all been done together I mean
and the reason why I used audacious is
there were bits of it that I sort of
vaguely try to admire but it just so
much all thrown together but you could
you could argue it's quite mesmerizing
yeah you could argue that that is the
only solution given the dire situation
Zoe that the country finds itself in
maybe the only solution is to throw the
kitchen sink at it
well I absolutely agree that we need
large-scale intervention but of course
it's totally at the government's choice
of how to do that who benefits and where
benefits so in response to your question
this is very much a sugar rush budget I
mean the the collection of measures are
Epic Proportion they go to the wrong
places but of course in the short term I
imagine there will be a short spike of
economic activity you know the stamp
Duty cut for instance you know might
stimulate some more activity in the
housing market but that's not what's
needed so we might see a short spike in
growth but I don't think anything has
changed in the fundamentals of our
economy for the longer term for the
longer term we need proper investment I
mean there are much better reasons to
invest in the UK than tax cuts I think
it's actually quite a pessimistic
narrative that we hear today that the
only reason that businesses want to do
business in the UK is if we do a race to
the bottom on all fronts on all taxes I
actually think there's a much more
positive story to tell about what we can
offer
um business and in the UK and I think an
investment story on skills on health and
would be a far stronger one than the one
we've seen today from budget okay um and
Andy your thoughts on growth it's all
about getting uh the country growing
again getting the economy growing again
giving them that sort of injection but
will it take uh one year two years five
years yes so some of the effects will be
immediate I think Zoe picked up on one
of the most effective which is
stimulating the housing market but she's
also absolutely right that the
government don't engage in serious
planning reform and not just in the
investment zones then that won't happen
it will just push up house prices which
again will price young people out of the
market so it's got to be both in the
longer term what we will see is some of
these tax effects stimulating investment
now or investment plans which could then
kick in in three five ten years energy
is a great example nothing in energy
gets done quickly so what we want to see
is people showing that confidence again
that the government's made the right
calls there but for that more supply
side reform is needed okay got quite a
specific question from Tony regarding
his personal situation he says I earn
more than 50 000 pounds a year and
nowhere near 100
000 pounds those earning ridiculous
amounts of money have just been given a
five percent bonus is that fair says
Tony I I have a feeling Zoe I know what
you might say to this
well according to analysis out today
um those under earning under 155 000
pounds will not benefit
um from the tax cuts today those over
155 000 pounds will and indeed those
earning over a million pounds will see a
tax cut of 40 000 pounds so
um I will leave it on the table for
people to decide for themselves but I
know that that will drive inequality
even further apart in this country
that's something I don't want to see and
that's something that will also in turn
have a drag on economic growth
uh Tim
listen I I wish there would be a none of
the fiscal stimulus or tax cuts uh and
of course as you've just heard by
definition it is helping all the
wealthier people
um much more than the others and it's
almost as though they deliberately want
to make a song and dance out of that
which frankly seems a bit odd but what
it should have been is a focus on really
concentrating on doing things to boost
our productivity which does involve
skills and education and proper
Investments and incentives for real risk
taking as opposed to this never-ending
nonsense about some small changing
corporate tax supposedly leading to some
miraculous boost in investment which has
been tried and tried again the past 20
years and we have one of the lowest
investment rates in the G20 and it is
really quite scary that this scale of
fiscal risk is taken at a time where we
have the lowest unemployment rate for 50
years
um whilst a lot of our inflation is
coming from Energy prices as the markets
are demonstrating as I say again as we
speak
this is a sign that the markets are
actually more worried about inflation
now because of what's been announced
today and it therefore it's sort of
defeating some of what the true probably
underlying genuine long-term purpose
which under has touched on a bit which
is to really raise the country's growth
potential but you do not doing do that
by giving mammoths tax cuts when the
economy is so close to such challenges
with the wages and full employment okay
do you agree with that Andy do you think
there was nothing there to help
investment to help training to to help
the workforce earn more and get out
there I mean that that's what quasi
quaten was saying wasn't he that there
are incentives now for people to to to
to work more work harder and and boost
productivity yeah and I think that is
work in progress this is a mini budget
not the full picture and let's remember
this government has been in place for
around about a month of which most of
which has been taken up by a national
tragedy so they haven't very much time
and what they're trying to do is send a
signal of what's to come but to go back
to the original question I don't think
it's a heroic Injustice that we've
restored the top rate of tax that
existed for the entirety of the labor
government that was last in by the last
year where they introduced the 50p rate
purely as a poison pill and an election
stunt to harm the Tories okay great
getting your thoughts thank you very
much for answering those questions
apologies if we didn't get around to
yours Andy mayor CEO at The Institute of
economic Affairs thank you Lord Jim
O'Neill former treasury Minister and
former Chief Economist at Golden Sachs
good to get your thoughts and also Zoe
Billingham director of the ippr north
Think Tank really good to get your say
and hear what you have to say about
today's mini budget thank you all do
stay with us here on Sky News Tonight
coming up in the next hour the pound
plunges following today's Major
announcements from the new Chancellor
we'll have all the latest reaction and
Analysis at the top of the hour
foreign
[Music]
there are now two billion people
shopping on laptops and phones 24 hours
in every Zone if you do business online
no need to do it alone
[Music]
we'll help you keep up with the clicks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's eight o'clock this is Sky News
Tonight our top story one of the biggest
economic interventions by a UK
government
we promised a new approach for a new era
we promised to release the enormous
potential of this country our growth
plan has delivered all those promises
and more
the chancellor announces a raft of tax
cuts and increases borrowing by billions
sending the value of the pound
plummeting
but there are some celebrations in the
city after the chancellor scrapped the
cap on Bankers bonuses in the further
boost for top earners
coming up we'll look at how the
financial markets have reacted and what
the changes mean to households and
businesses also tonight
voting gets underway in referenda in
Moscow controlled areas of Ukraine
Western Nations call the votes a sham
we report from a newly liberated Village
in Harrison just a few miles from the
Russian occupied region as some
residents start to return home
almost impossible to watch the Instagram
Clips viewed by Molly Russell as shown
at the inquest into her death